we had the subject matter of this 34:30
on last week and now the 3430 is about
to air on ESPN it's called 42 to 1
it's about Buster Douglas beating Mike
Tyson and the co-director the man behind
42 to 1 along with Ben Houser
one of my good friends love this man
Jeremy shap here on the show how you
been Jeremy I don't get to see you know
enough Richard mutual but but I've been
well Ben sends his regards as well
that's right run prompter for you I know
that member used to hand me shot sheets
in the middle of the night we're doing
2:30 in the morning
I'm sure you remind rich that I was I
was his prompter operator when I was
coming up and look now he's a big
director no no so he does speak well
with me though right Jeremy he does he
does everybody ESPN does at the
mothership
I can't believe it's been like it's been
like 25 years still felt 15 every day
Jeremy is 15 it's just 15 but whatever I
am I am sort of the Mike Holmgren of
broadcasting in the fact that everybody
thinks I've been at ESPN longer than NFL
Network and I've actually been at NFL
Network twice as long as I was ever at
ESPN in the same way he spent more time
in Seattle than he did Green Bay and
then other than that there are no other
analogies I can make to that I'm trying
to think is there anything else with
Holmgren uh no it's been a tarry to
write not a vegetarian a lot of time in
the Midwest both of you are from the
coast there's been a lot of time in the
Midwest yes and we both sing doo-wop in
our spare time no that's just had that's
just him not me Jeremy why'd you make
this because I mean look we're the same
age and there was something about this
moment in time for me this remains the
most thrilling with the possible
exception the miracle on ice and you
know a couple of things as a New York
sports fan that have occurred over the
years the most thrilling thing I've ever
seen in sports and certainly one of the
most unexpected Mike Tyson as you well
know was a colossus he was the biggest
star in sports nobody thought Buster
Douglas had a chance and there's nothing
bigger in sports than the heavyweight
championship you could say it's been
diminished in the last couple of
generations you know the Klitschkos kind
of ran away with them
Europe and we didn't see him for a while
but the heavyweight title is still
something of mythic significance in
sports and Buster Douglas became the
undisputed heavyweight champion of the
world the lineal champion the man who
you know beat the man who beat the man
who beat the man all the way back to
John L Sullivan in the biggest upset in
sports history and he didn't do it with
luck it wasn't a fluke as you know you
interviewed Buster last week
this was a 10-round ass-kicking and the
one second in the fight that he wasn't
really dominating the eighth round he
gets lured by a Tyson uppercut which
would have ended the fight any of
Tyson's previous 37 fights he gets up
off the canvas after getting rocked like
that and seven or eight minutes later
he's the heavyweight champion of the
world there's there's no other story
like it and and yet I don't think people
really know the Buster Douglas story we
know the Mike Tyson story nobody's told
the Mike Tyson story more than I have
frankly over the last like 20 years and
this is this is buster story this is
about the guy who won the fight and we
we did speak to him last week and just
you know give me your favorite story
that you learned through this about
Buster Douglas that you didn't know
already going in I mean there's a lot
there I mean in terms of a story and I
think one of the things if I may say so
the credit really does go to our friend
Ben Hauser he really did all the work
here one of the things that the film
does well is weave these stories
together with different voices telling a
full story and one of those stories is
after the fight is made and Buster gets
his shot at Mike Tyson and he sees it as
this remarkable operatory his second
title shot in heavyweight division to
win that crown his mother Lula pearl
Douglas asks his father who had been a
great prizefighter himself bill Douglas
you know about this Mike Tyson guys he
really as scary as everybody says and
bill Douglas says yeah he really is
so she goes to Buster's house that night
to talk him out of fighting Mike Tyson
we're talking about you know a guy who
was you know a heavyweight contender he
was the number-two contender at the time
take the IBS number-two contender maybe
even moved up to number one at that
point he's a guy who fought for the
heavyweight title before he's from a
boxing family and his brothers or
heavyweights his father's a middleweight
light heavy and his mother goes to his
house to tell him you can't fight this
guy he's too scary and he says to his
mom no no don't be worried about me be
worried about that guy you know I think
you can't make this stuff up and you
know what it turned out Buster was right
Jeremy shap here on the Rich Eisen show
and having Buster on last week it was a
fun moment for me where I was able to
thank him for helping me procrastinate
in my studies as a senior at the
University of Michigan we are of the
same age but I you know Jeremy might
have a little bit more on the shoulders
than you because I skipped kindergarten
back in the day to be a great ahead of
you and the rest of all of us in our
that's why your classes yes so you were
a junior in Cornell if I'm not mistaken
when the half what were you skipping out
of classes to see this do you remember
where you were it was a weekend so there
were no classes but I mean it was on
prime time in the u.s. it was an
afternoon fight on a Sunday in Tokyo
Japan at the Tokyo Dome and they were
fighting it was about 11 o'clock Eastern
Time I think about 8 o'clock I mean it
would have been obviously 8 o'clock West
Coast time I think it was 11 8 maybe it
was more like 12 9 and I was in of all
places that boxing hotbed Hanover New
Hampshire covering a college hockey game
contested between the very formidable
big red of Cornell and they're not so
formidable big green of Dartmouth and I
was trying to find somewhere to watch
the fight it was on regular HBO right
and back you know in in the dark days of
cable television it was hard to find
regular HBO in a place like Hanover New
Hampshire I could not but I'd asked
around
some people Dartmouth that they had it
they didn't or at least they told me
they didn't maybe they just didn't want
me hanging out out with them watching
the fight
and then later in the night I ran into
some guy who I'd asked earlier and I he
said did you hear what happened
of course like everybody else I was
stunned I was floored you know III had
made an attempt to see it because I was
a fight fan in particular fan of the
heavyweight division but I was like yeah
what's the big deal anyway right well of
course and it ended up being a huge deal
but you'll like this Richard because you
are a student of history a consummate
student of history connoisseur a
consummate I'm a connoisseur yes and
it's consequential as it was seven hours
later something much more consequential
took place on the planet that was the
lead story the next day in the New York
Times rather than Buster Douglas
defeating Mike Tyson do you have any
idea what not be being despite being the
connoisseur that you did point out to me
fill in the blanks for me Jeremy what
was it Nelson Mandela walked free after
more than a quarter century in prison
about seven hours after Buster Douglas
became the heavyweight champion of the
world walked out of victor Verster
prison see that's you Jeremy being you
right there that's your next level right
there that's your next no that's another
reason why think about that I mean you
know you got this massive event in
sports and then you've got this massive
event for the entire planet taking place
right right right right what does your
dad think of the fight well what was his
take you know when he heard about it
Jeremy I mean you know I I didn't go
back it would have been interesting go
back and look at the sports reporters
from that morning but the sports
reporters which of course was on on
Sunday mornings back then would have
been the first place where many people
found out about the outcome because you
know a lot of people were in bed by the
time it ended around midnight and people
wake up would wake up on Sunday mornings
then and turn on ESPN and my father he
was just doing the sports reporters he
was like doing the remember that Sunday
morning like hosting thing he would do
typically was Robin Roberts sure and you
know she'd be in bristling he'd be in
New York so you know actually I should
have gone back and looked exactly at
what they had to say but he'd been to a
lot of Tyson fights at that point I'm
sure he's as stunned as everybody else
if he hadn't been he would have put
money on
Jeremie shop here on the Rich Eisen show
this is another reason why you're
perfect for this sort of stuff Jeremy
for this piece and in general for the
amount of you know boxing you were
exposed to as a kid through your dad
give me your favorite Ollie's story when
did you first meet him when did you just
walk into the house one day and he's
sitting there in the living room did
that happen oh yeah definitely I
remember I remember him being around my
first memories though I remember going
to see him at his home in Cherry Hill
New Jersey I think that would have been
around 74 75 I was only four or five but
I remember it and then I remember
spending time around him in the
Catskills when he was training for one
of the Ken Norton fights you know he
fought more than three times I don't
remember which one specifically it's so
you know he was kind of a constant
presence around you know in my day we're
so close my dad knew him before he went
to Rome is an 18 year old to fight in
the Olympics when he gets back from Rome
you know he's coming through New York my
father was at Newsweek they spent the
whole day together my father spent the
night and all he's sweet my father had
to have Olli call his wife at the time
his first wife - you know - thou trim
that he was actually with the champ he
wasn't doing something he should have
been doing but but there's so many great
Ally stories I mean the two that
immediately come to mind one one and my
dad a lot one is uh 1969 early 70 my
father's with Tom Seabreeze just written
a book with Tom Seaver Tom Seavers
arguably the biggest star in sports at
that point the miracle Mets he was
twenty five and five I guess or 25 and
three whatever it was he wins Desai
Young Award he wins the World Series all
that stuff he's reading a book during a
promotional tour there in Chicago where
Muhammad was living at the time he was
banned from boxing at the time fighting
that fight to get to Chicago my dad says
hey you want to go out dinner you know
with Muhammad Seaver says of course I'd
love to meet Muhammad Ali they go out to
dinner they have one of these big
dinners for hours at some steak house
and Ali's holding Cortese telling
stories he's talking about himself in
the third person
and finally at the end of the night
they're wrapping it up to paying the
check
Mohammed turns to Tom see Bernie says
Tom you're a nice fella what paper you
write for say anything during the whole
dinner Ali just assumed that he was a
newspaper guy like my dad that's
fantastic and then one guy is actually
there for my dad and I happen to be
tagging along my dad and Ali were
watching the second Tyson Bruno fight I
think it was 90 I have something like
that right after Tyson got out of prison
and my dad there's there women fighting
on the undercard which was a novelty at
the time and we're in New York watching
on TV and my father says Tolley says
champ what do you think about this
woman's fighting he takes a pause and
then at this point his voice you know
was was really husky and he says I only
like it when they're fighting over me
and and that was that was vomit you know
it always there great man hey Jeremy
love you pal Congrats on this you got it
Cinderella man the story about James J
Braddock Max Baer and the greatest upset
in boxing history who's one of your
best-selling books let's see what else
to host the weekly radio show and
podcast the sporting life right Jeremy
that's right okay when you're when
you're not interviewing the lacrosse
camp of Bowdoin College and you want to
have me on you know you know let's I'm
more than happy to do it whatever you do
you know I wouldn't even even dream of
asking you to be on my little show but
but it don't say it's your little show
it's a long-running program of note
let's put it that way no that's that's
no man I'd say it's a long-running
program of little no no more accurate no
but you know
Emily I'm seeing your recent guest Ricky
Williams Gotham Chopra was on our show
last week Gracie I don't call this a
little show Jeremy and kind of
aggressively discourages people from
listening uh you know one of my favorite
segments we've had over the years just
two friends talking so years ago I had
on the show the great photographer
George kolinsky Madison Square Garden
official photographer he had a new book
out and of course it's always hard to
have photographers on the radio because
you know described but not only did I
have George on the show and he wasn't
talking about all the great fights he
shot and all the great basketball that
he had just published a book about
rabbis all over the world
shooting rabbis all over the world of
course my show was on on Saturday
mornings anyone who's actually observant
would not have been able to listen but
George kolinsky talking about his rabbi
book that's kind of the typical fare on
this for tea all right so then let me
let me bring my level of sports acumen
and Judaism to the situation as well
okay Jeremy whenever you can everyone go
ahead okay work me and work me into the
rotation
Jeremy anytime thanks for coming on here
let me know when you're out here in LA
you're welcome back here any time as
well I can't wait to see 4201 your 34:30
tonight on ESPN at 9:00 Eastern Time the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience